more than 13 million people live in
metro manila
the air is thick and not just with
humidity
pollution has long been a problem here
according to the world health
organization
the philippines has an exceptionally
high rate of air pollution related
deaths
postal delivery worker albert lazada
struggles to make his way through this
congestion every morning
but he's one of the few people in the
city with an e-moped
and can travel from a to b quietly and
without creating any emissions
here in the pasic district of manila i
would always go by e-moped
given the choice it's quieter
and it doesn't pollute the air you also
save on gas money
the other motorbikes around me are
really loud i feel much more relaxed on
my moped
it's a lot less stressful
my stress the philippines electric
postal fleet is part of a model project
that is co-funded by the united nations
and the philippine
energy ministry a total of 30 vehicles
already run on electricity
metro manila wants to become an
environmental pioneer
and cut traffic congestion with new
concepts
pasig is one of 10 model cities
worldwide
where electromobility is being promoted
with funding from the eu and the
international
climate initiative but it's not that
simple
and the mayor of pasig knows just how
urgently
change is needed
climate change and air pollution are
definitely problems
for us globally right but here in pasig
there's a highly urbanized city
in the middle of metro manila air
pollution is definitely a big problem
recently we just completed our
greenhouse gas inventory
and we see that the rates of air
pollution in the city are
alarming to say the least and we need to
do whatever we can to lower these
numbers
in the near future tojo motors wants to
profit from this switch to
electromobility
based to the south of metro manila for
seven years now it has been building a
range of electric vehicles
including these jeep knees
currently tojo motors still imports all
its components from china
the vision is actually producing and
engineering
locally for our local customers
so our mission is to have filipino
people
enjoy electric vehicles as their mode of
transportation for public
and private but the company still relies
on support from the philippine
government
and the european union plus e-mobility
has yet to properly take off in the
country
and the technical specifications have
yet to be finalized
the heart of the whole thing will is the
electric battery
and we need to get a good mix between
okay the
size of the battery and what would be
affordable for the
for the for the market at the moment
hardly anyone buys electric cars in the
philippines for private use
nifty is a startup that builds folding
bicycles
and originally electric ones too but
with that business proving unprofitable
the two founders now only upgrade bikes
with batteries
the parts that we get costs the same
as a whole e-bike that you get from
china so for a start-up it's very
difficult
to compete especially in such a new
market such
a market where it's very price sensitive
income fourie is the startup's
co-founder
he and his team make standard folding
bikes he's a cycling enthusiast
and keen to contribute to efforts to
reduce traffic congestion
our cities were not designed to have
other modes of transportation especially
among two wheeled lightweight
transportation ones
so if your seat is not
meant for bicycles electric bicycles
would also be
challenging electro mobility comes at a
high price
it's still too expensive for most people
and it also hasn't gained widespread
acceptance among the population
according to the mayor of pasig
nevertheless
the desire for a cleaner and more
environmentally friendly city
is growing so what would the people we
talk to like to see
30 years from now i hope that congestion
will have eased by 2050.
particularly if more people use electric
vehicles whether they're motorbikes
bicycles or cars
i hope there'll be more of them because
it will improve traffic
in 2050 hopefully it's a city where in
all modes of transportation are not just
accepted but widely used
where private vehicles do not dominate
the roads
the vehicles are not owned by the people
but instead you buy the service
and that is strongly anchored on smart
solutions
wherein mobility plays a major role
in 2050 i hope that metro manila
embraces
cycling as an infrastructure as a way
for people to move around
you know we have bike lanes here that
take us around the different cities
covered with trees it's a vision that
seems a world away from the current
congested reality of manila
by 2050 up to 23 million people will
live in the region
making the need for new mobility
concepts all the more pressing
you